estambul se ha convertido en el nuevo
hogar de muchos rusos opuestos a la
guerra de vladimir putin en ucrania
incluyendo a engine a ella trabaja como
periodista independiente en moscú pero
decidió huir por su seguridad
fue una de las decisiones más difíciles
que he tomado tuve que tomarla
rápidamente no sabía por cuánto tiempo
tendría que irme así que hice una maleta
cogí mi cámara y me fui y viajo a una
nueva ley en rusia amenaza con hasta 15
años de cárcel por difundir información
falsa sobre la invasión de ucrania
muchos periodistas del país se han
dirigido desde entonces a turquía
no somos traidores amamos a rusia y
queremos volver es nuestra casa no la de
putin
ni quina sigue informando desde estambul
filmando a otros exiliados rusos maya es
una activista contra la guerra y trabajo
como directora de teatro en san
petersburgo donde su pareja permanece
atrapado
tengo mucho miedo por mi novio porque
puede ser realmente enviado al ejército
sabes
por ahora creo que está a salvo así que
podemos elegir la cárcel o el ejército
de familias rusas enteras también han
hecho el viaje brad y maría que se
oponen a putin trabajan en la industria
del cine huyeron con su bebé y ahora se
alojan con un amigo
limpiado mi computador porque también
estoy produciendo películas de
resistencia documentales contra el
régimen así que tuve que llevar conmigo
la familia continúa su resistencia en
estambul no a la guerra gloria ucraniano
a la guerra en rusia las protestas no
autorizadas están prohibidas
en rusia ahora no sería libre
físicamente no tendría ninguna
posibilidad de tener la mínima voz
con el espacio aéreo de la unión europea
cerrado a los salones rusos es probable
que está un bulls sigue siendo un
destino clave para los rusos que buscan
escapar de la creciente represión del
kremlin contra la libertad de expresión